recovering in her hospital bed it's been
a terrible 10 days for lisa king
her breathing is slowly returning to
normal but it was touch and go at times
the 51 year old wishes she'd had the
vaccine and is now urging others to get
the jab i've never experienced nothing
like this in my life
and
it's it's nothing i'd want anyone else
to him
it's been tough
the flow of coveted patients at this
hospital has been relentless throughout
the pandemic but two epidemics coming
now on top of each other delta and
omicron they are preparing for worse to
come
this is the intensive care unit where
the most critically ill patients are
brought for treatment many of the people
here are on ventilators now at the
moment the hospital is coping but the
fear is with the omicron variant
taking off in the community that
hospital admissions will soon rise
sharply
the patients here most likely all have
the delta variant
in one of the beds we meet david colley
a fit 39 year old he has been double
jabbed but still ended up in icu
yeah
i was on the um
i was on the ward for two days not
deteriorated so they've had to bring me
in here
i've been in here four weeks now today
i've been in here
now go to the gym three or four times a
week
mountain bike
never off sick
it's just just knocked me off my face
now you just say you don't think it's
going to happen
i've been double jabbed
as well
may and july if i was jabbed
um and i did say if i better have been
vaccinated i probably wouldn't be here
for the medical staff these are
frustrating days the vast majority of
patients here have not been vaccinated
with another big wave of infections
coming they are worried about the next
few weeks so all of the meetings that
we've attended in so far as the network
is concerned where modelling is taking
place
the message is clear that this looks
like it's the calm before the storm
government scientists say omicron
infections are now moving at a
phenomenal pace
and at the start of this new wave medics
here are already exhausted
initially it was
all hands on deck everyone was full of
energy and but as the time's gone on it
seems like there's there's no ending to
it
the infectiousness of omicron also
brings new challenges as well as making
more space for patients there is the
risk to those working on the front line
we are absolutely worried about a not
only just having enough staff here but
also the impact that it has on staff who
are well having to work additional
shifts having to work that flexibility
and to show that that resilience that we
ask again of our staff again and again
no one here knows what omicron will
bring over the christmas period
they hope the explosion in infection
rates will not lead to a surge in
admissions
but the data does not look good
alex rossi sky news
wolverhampton